شنو اسرائيل باستمرار ضربات تستهدف مواقع
تابعه لحزب الله اللبناني المدعوم من
طهران اخرى تابعه للنظام السوري ومستودعات
اسلحه وذخائر في محيط دمشق وداخله مطارات
مدنيه وعسكريه في مناطق متفرقه نادرا
متاكد الدوله العبريه في ضربات في سوريا
لكنها تكرر انها ستواصل تصديها لما تصفه
بمحاولات ايران لترسيخ وجودها العسكري
هناك سنخصص مشاهدينا الكرام وقفه الحدث
لهذا اليوم مع زميل عبد الله العالي لهذا
الملف اهلا بك عبد الله هل من المعلومات
اجمل عن اهداف الغاره الاسرائيليه الجديده
التي استهدفت مطار دمشق الدولي
قبل قليل ااه رئيس مصر السوري لحقوق
الانسان هذه الضربات او الغارات
الصاروخيه التي استهدفت بالاساس مواقع
تابعه لحزب الله او ت علي حركات او
مجموعات بالاحرى تابعه لايران
وحسب ما فات وهو المصدر الرئيسي حتى الان
عن هذه الغاره فان هنالك مستوعب مستودعا
للاسلحه
بمحيطي مطاره دمشق قد تم تدميره ولكننا
نعرف بالمجمل بان الاسرائيليين يقولون همم
بانهم يريدون تحقيق عده اهداف من خلال
مئات الضربات التي شموها على سوريا منذ
بدايه الحرب الاهليه عام 2011 من ذلك منع
ايران من همم تكرار انموذج همم مشابه لحزب
الله في سوريا اقامتي تنظيم موال لها يقوم
باستهدافه اسرائيل عبر ضربات
خاصه بالصواريخ انطلاقه من الاراضي
السوريه وانها من اجل ذلك الغرض همم تنفذ
بشكل دوري عمليات هدفها اما استهداف
مقاتلين تابعين لايران داخل
او همم استهدافي مستودعات للذخيره اا او
استهداف قول قوافل
لتحمل اسلحه من سوريا الى لبنان همم الذي
يوجد فيه المقر الرئيسي لحزب الله اذا هذه
الضربه لا تخرج عن هذا همم السياق
الاسرائيلي لهذا المطار بالتحديد عبد الله
في الواقع هذا سؤال وجيه لان الاسرائيليين
لم يستهدفوا مطار دمشق الا في الاشهر
الاخيره الابتداء من السنه الماضيه وخلال
اكثر من 11 سنه لم يكن مطار دمشق محل
للاستهداف لكنه بدا يستهدف حينما وصلت
معلومات الى الاسرائيليين وهذا طبعا وفقا
للروايه الاسرائيليه تفيد بانه اصبح
يستخدم كا محطه لنزول طائرات شح تحمل
اسلحه ثقيله مواجهه لحزب الله من ايران
وانه ايضا تم استخدامه القاعده الجويه في
مدينه تدمر في الباديه السوريه لهذا الغرض
بنفسه بل انهم ذهبوا ابعدم ذلك اذ قالوا
بان ايران عمدت الى نقل معدات متطوره على
طائرات نقل مدني في رحلات مدنيه همم بهدف
ايصالها لحزب الله وان تلك المعدات
المتطوره تستخدم في صنع اسلحه في صنع
الصواريخ بامكانها ان تستهدف الاراضي
الاسرائيليه وفقا للروايات الاسرائيليه
ذاتها ومن اجل ذلك تم توجيه هذه الضربات
لمطار دمشق تحديدا ولكن ايضا لمطار همم
لمطار حلب الذي يعد ثاني اكبر مطار في
البلاد في سبتمبر ايلولا الماضي
وكذلك كلمات اللاذقيه الذي يعتبر ايضا احد
الموانئ السوريه التي تم استخدامه وفقه
استخدامها وفقا لروايه الاسرائيليه لنقل
اسلحه ومعدات متطوره الى حزب الله لذلك
فان هذا الاستداف يتعلق باستخدام هذه
المنشئه المدنيه
لاغراض نقل اسلحه ومعدات عسكريه متطوره
وفقا الروايتي الاسرائيليه علما بان الامم
المتحده حينما استهدف مطار دمشق في يونيو
حزيره حزيران الماضي وتم تدمير عدد كبير
من المدرجاته وتعطيله عن العمل لمده
اسبوعين ادانت ذلك واعتبرته خرقا للقانون
الدولي الذي يحرم استهداف المنشات المدنيه
عبد الله ماذا عن موقف روسيا حليفه سوريا
والتي لها تواجد عسكري هناك
الروس هنالك يجب ان ندرك اولا ان هنالك
اتفاقيه سريه عسكريه بين الاسرائيليين
والروس بهذا الشعب وسبق لهم اتفاقا يرمي
الى تفادي اي اشتباك مسلح بين اسرائيل
وروسيا على الاراضي السوريه لذلك الغرض
فان هنالك كثيقا بينهما فيما يتعلق بهذه
العمليه بمعنى ان الاسرائيليين عاده ما
يخبرون الروس مسبقا حينما يكونون بقصد
ولديهم النيه باستهداف مواقع داخل الاراضي
السوريه سواء كان ذلك عبر غارات صاروخيه
او عبر غارات تنفذها الطائرات
ولذلك فان الموقف التقليديه لروسيا هو انت
تحفل وان لا تدليه بتصريح ينعل نيه بهذا
الشعر لكن همم في حينما استهتف مطار دمشق
في حزيران الماضي همم وكبت او سيرت روسيا
على الاحرار بالاحرى الموقبه الذي اتخذته
الامم المتحده وقالت بان تلك الغاره كانت
تمثل استفزازا وانها مخالفه لقانون الدولي
لانها استهدفت مدنيه شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
الله العالي على كل هذه التفاصيل